[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very excited to be talking about all
things comedy all things political
correctness in our culture and in comedy
very excited to be having John Howland
joining us on the show hello how's it
going thanks for coming on really
appreciate it and I'm really grateful
that we had the opportunity to meet
several years ago and I've been to your
cheaper than therapy events multiple
times that you've been producing for six
years now yeah six years of cheaper than
therapy
this is and this is crazy because you do
315 of these every year yeah we built up
to build up to yeah yeah yeah just jump
in it yeah and do six a week but right
it's very badass that you do six of
these a week and you see you have 20,000
people that you entertain every single
year yeah sure we sell out every weekend
and so it's been a good I'm tired I'm
tired yeah yeah and you have a cool
series that you've started as well
called cheaper than therapy that links
in the bio John's links are in the bio
the cheap in therapies in the bio
forever coming through the Bay Area we
highly highly recommend it sits at
Shelton Theatre in Union Square to check
out cheap in therapy
John's hilariously up was previously a
physicist now he's turned stand-up
comedian so we talking about that
transition as well and let's jump into
things on a big history perspective we
find ourselves as stewards of earth what
is your current take on the state of
humanity not good I don't know it seems
like it seems like as a species were
destined for self-destruction which is
not something you find a lot of other
species doing to themselves
I mean on the whole we had a good pretty
good run I think it was
we sure did it's reasonable it was it
was a good try we did a valiant effort
and let's just hang it up and just start
my goal is I think we should put I know
that this is life but that we should put
like the free beer it has a
sterilization so people will tell them
well tell them that it's got
stabilization I'm not gonna trick
anybody but you also get free beer and I
think that and I think a lot of people
would go for that they just get free
beer and then there's no more kids and I
think that that's I mean that's the more
people the more people is the problem
but the number of people is the problem
like 8 billion people is 7 billion
people too many are you aware the
Georgia Guidestones
the way the Georgia Guidestones they
recommend you keep us the population of
about 500 million on the planet yeah and
you do things like you you see you're
very intelligent about the way that you
make laws and that you reproduce oh yeah
that's not gonna happen that's not gonna
that's not gonna happen
we need the biggest problem at least in
America and America it's like the the
driver of all this crap at the moment I
think is that we're so spread out as you
know suburbia is what is murdering the
planet mmm is that when people are
densely packed together then they're
more educated more aware more
availability of resources and if you
have the means and education to say like
oh I can be on birth control and bony
responsibly and then people who'll do
that they don't like Mowgli
almost everybody wasn't wanted so it's
not like a big unwanted then I certainly
don't want them now so it's it's a like
at some point in time they're not there
it's really once an interesting
statistic what percentage of children
are actually wanted maybe like probably
I mean over their whole life because I'm
good once they hit like three just like
I'm done with this game so what would
you say the the
the most the what what variables do you
give the greatest weight to which give
you the feeling that humanity should
just you know this is not going well
well first of all with the the the
discussion that we can't have a
discussion about that there are just too
many people there just it's just too
many people it's not that's I mean
that's the discussion that politicians
should be having like well how do we not
get rid of the people that are here but
maybe you know curtail know the thing is
create jobs for all these fees yeah
that's not a good situation don't
encourage them unless that job takes up
a hundred percent of their target and
they don't have time to bone anymore and
can't make kids like that's kind of
what's happening I mean that's yeah I
mean that's sort of but that doesn't
yeah it doesn't really stop the process
some of the argument of some of these
leading public intellectuals has been
that it if resources were managed in
extremely sustainable environmentally
conscious ways and we could easily put
billions of people out into the the
cosmos and in no I'm sorry like it's too
this thing's too far away like if you
look at if you look at the the
essentially like was bored in class one
day and was like the closest to the
Bright Starts is serious it's like eight
point eight light years away closest
stars alpha Proxima and which is like
five point seven light years away or
something like that point two five so
it's four four five whatever I'm a as
fitzy just round up to some whole number
it's close by the point being is that if
you were if the entire earth were a
grain of sand and we're on a beach in
California the the closest star in the
in Northern California
the closest star in the sky is on it is
a larger grain of sand a much larger
grain it's a rock on the on the coast in
in Galveston or Florida like that it's
that far away
and it's not it's not reasonable to have
an expectation that we that we're gonna
leave here and
you know well yeah maybe not even not
even text message you sent a text
message to somebody 4.4 long years away
or maybe maybe here's a maybe here's a
better way to structure that ghosted I
didn't find out that I got ghosted for
like 36 years out of that take takes
take something like why don't you take
something like the way that you just
read that you that you use the resources
of the host rock that you live on if you
do it in a very sustainable way that's
conscious and friendly with the planet
and that if you do it through nuclear
fusion or through harvesting solar
energy all different sorts there's all
different ways to do this that you could
potentially unleash the creative minds
if you I think really well right now
they mean that's a that's I think it's I
think so
I I had somebody that kept pestering me
when I was giving a lecture one time and
they kept asking me about string theory
stuff and I don't do string theory that
they they wanted to ask about like I was
doing constrained Hamiltonian dynamics
they want to know about string theory
blah blah blah how's this apply and I'm
like look I had to stop because I was
interrupting the lecture now as I look
questions for the sake of questions is
theology or is philosophy right there's
a whole department hmm for that answers
for the sake of answers is theology
there's another department for that
questions for the sake of answers is
science hmm that's what we do we take
incremental steps so while these maybe
Big Pine is quiet sky questions I don't
think that they're like the incremental
steps we have more prescient problems
which is like how can we not get a
hundred million dollars cut from NSF
funding this year you know and why did
the movie gravity cost more to make than
all of the money that was used to fund
gravity research in the last 10 years
like how is how are those two things
yeah I just made that up
but it was I'm sure I'm sure it sounds
right it sounds right it sounds like the
right thing it feels right it feels
right that's what matters
but like I was like questions for the
sake of answers that's what you should
be looking for and answers for the sake
of questions let's jeopardy comes
three we got a rabbit over okay okay
okay so there's you you bring up this
good point which is this really bright
future that you envision and that these
Millennials and Gen Z kids are the
envision building it has to have these
actionable steps that we need to take in
order to increase the science funding
make sure that we're not birthing kids
that are they're depleted of nutrients
that they need in order to maximize the
potential of them into the world there's
like all these short-term things that we
need to focus on and that's kind of
where some of your maybe your your I
think I think that's the incremental
like science is an incremental process
you have a large-scale direction if you
build a company you have an increment
lean startup whatever you have an
incremental process or it's like I want
to get to this thing at the end and I
think this is sort of like we're you
know because things have been so
stagnant and impossible or regressive in
the political sphere for so long that
you know I think a lot of Millennials
are upset they just wanted to change
drastically mmm right now and I think
that I mean this probably why I'm not a
millennial or I definitely am in the
thing but I don't I don't call people I
text people and if they call me I get
upset so I guess there's like certain
things that I'm a little animal about
but I want I want incremental change I
want to see somebody that's saying like
here's what we want to do at the end of
the day and here's here's a plan for
incremental process yes to that and I
want you know the biggest change would
need to be the paradigm of like how
people understand what information is
yes and that's that's the biggest threat
to humanity at the moment is
brainwashing it's not it's a pre
built-in component where it's like I
want to feel like I belong to a group
and I want to feel smart and you mean
that's a good you get a reward you get a
reward system like that if you didn't
have the reward that of having learned
something you get a reward I mean a
large part of the US population at least
has by prawns bypassed the learning
aspect of it and they go directly to the
reward oh well I saw it on will say
Fox News website whatever I saw it on
Facebook and Facebook and now I'm no now
I'm you know and you see it you see it
in you know if you look at like mental
illness or something like that you see a
lot of like the edge cases of how the
human brain works yeah and you know
that's where you get a lot of the
conspiracy components as well and I
think that everybody is is susceptible
to it and science is the is the process
of removing what you want to be true and
challenging what you want to be true in
order to be deeply unhappy all of your
life also science comes with no money so
I don't know why that's a very very
crucial point is that if this is funding
science and making science more of a
process of inquiry for friend critical
thinking for children when their first
birth into the world will eliminate a
lot of the potential errors and
malevolence --is that we now have today
I don't think we need to do it just for
kids I think it's possible to teach an
adult like yeah Howard what are the
things how do you spot fake news yeah
totally
here's how totally here's how I spot
faking it well first of all wait like
what other references are pointing to it
like you know it's it's something that's
just one-off and then all references
point to the same initial source is it
reputable like does it have some I'm
more likely to to be inclined to trust
something that has a reputation do they
do if it's print media or even if it's
not do they do corrections and do they
list the directions so one of the great
things about I found it to be the case
if a and I don't agree with everything
about Wall Street Journal says some it
was like that but they have a print
edition and the print edition forces you
to make decisions at a certain time and
then do something about it and that
process filters up to any way in which
you get additional you know web
or something else like that and the in
the process of that gives you
corrections and history of Corrections
yeah you can't own print a newspaper so
you have to print Corrections unpublish
a webpage very easily the last one is
and this is really this is goes to the
heart of why it's very easy to get into
fights on Twitter grammar and spelling
but fundamentally tell you if the person
cares enough if you can't care about
correcting and finding grammar and
spelling mistakes then you can't care
enough to find the facts it's a very
indicative component at least for me
like if there's a spelling if there's a
spelling error I'd like a just a blatant
one or a horrible grammar error I'm on
to the next thing I'm just I can't read
the article so you're bringing up of an
important point about about about really
looking at news media and figuring out
across all social as well and just
figuring out what's true and what's not
there's a lot of signal out there but it
needs to really get more and more
attention and eyeballs on that as a
foundation of truth and that's a really
good way to maybe solve some of the
issues that we have well I think if we
look at if we look at how a lot so
there's the news retainment component of
news which is you know when you think of
like The Daily Show or now last week
tonight with John Oliver which is that
they do it they do a great job I think
that there is fundamentally a
relationship between something that is
blatantly true and how you receive and
understand information and comedy yeah I
think that those things are
fundamentally related agreed yeah and I
think that's up to rid of some of the
best comics in the world have done a
really good job at making the true
things in the foundation of science more
visible and
easier to to laugh about and understand
I just thought I telling jokes I don't
do that I don't I don't
[Laughter]
different I think there's a different
thing when you're like I my goal is not
so like it's they entertain people I
mean I that's the one when I started
Chiba therapy its customer service
oriented a comedy club which is I I'm
not everyone's not gonna be happy but it
should be something where I did my best
and made sure that everybody else tried
to book the people that also want to do
their best to entertain people as
opposed to like push some agenda
represent yourself
sure represent your voice yeah but yeah
you know I it's different it's different
for like this you know the Daily Show or
last week two knives doughnuts like that
where if they they do have a story to
tell it vice news hasn't sure you know
they do the same trope of like way I
watched frontline I watched frontline
the PBS series because the intro music
tells me oh you're being smart good job
John you're doing something that's good
for your brain like it's the intro music
that just tells me you know that that
voice of the front the front line it's
it's telling me like oh you're doing a
good job and learning something I don't
I don't know if they're doing it like
you you know you you initially bring up
and you're on your big history
perspective you bring up like the state
of humanity having issues to deal with
at the same time like one of the things
that comedians can do is help Society
think more critically about things like
you mentioned with the news feed and
stuff like that is they passing along
jokes the audience is about about how a
lacking of critical thinking or about
success of critical thinking making
people have it that sounds like a bummer
of a comedy club to go them to actually
well I guess I from my standpoint from
my standpoint my job is everybody has
had a shitty week just assume everyone's
had a shitty week they've entrusted me
with their Friday night okay let's go
out and my job is to make them laugh
laughter lowers the temperature if you
can if you've had a bad week if you're
you know bundled up about something like
people are the right or the left people
with the same just if you come out and
laugh if you can't laugh then don't
[ __ ] come out mmm if you're so if
you're so pent up and you you're gonna
be you know upset and outraged about
everything just don't stay at home stay
at home and just let it run out the
clock a comedy has significant
physiological benefits I completely
completely agree and a lot of people you
can find comic material that can
resonate for a bit for lots of shapes
different it's a different shirt because
this one has pit stains in it and that
one doesn't have that was known as a
cleaner that was a cleaner and new dirt
yeah
also I didn't the beard was shorter than
at the time yeah balding still balding
but but nothing quite like the beard on
the hobo oh yeah that's different that's
a different situation that for that one
what's that a year this was a year of
growing the beard there's probably over
a year those back when I was in Austin
yeah
in indolent everyday everyday it should
be a comma but that's too lazy a lazy
smart person lazy smart person yeah it's
so good dude it's so good this one's a
litte yeah so good and I'm glad that you
got some of these photos they can just
just you know fun so okay but now you
can lead us into this for a bit so so
Texas born Austin trained in physics and
then tell us about how that had that how
that interest in physics started then
your hatred of a academia pushed you
today yeah I think well I mean I think
outside of academia you have this
austere sort of like oh you get to sit
and work on your problem and that's not
what it is you know hey the reason I got
into physics is because I started out I
love computers and sewing I started out
doing computer science and everybody was
like I'm gonna make ninety thousand
dollars yet which was a lot back in 2000
I'm old and I was like I don't okay care
I just want to talk about like Colonels
and schedulers and things like that and
so I left I went to robotics for like
five seconds and everybody was ten times
worse there and then I went to
six in pure math and no one said
anything about the jobs they were gonna
get they were just like hey look at this
math thing and I was like these are my
people these are like they don't like
it's in the worst building on UT campus
it's really like if you if you would
tell somebody how to get to the rlm
which is named after a racist
mathematician by the way we didn't
believe in the null belongs in the same
but anyways uh yeah Robert Lee Moore
building you could just follow the ugly
people and if you followed the ugly
people you would end up at the at the
rlm it's a it's a beautiful place they
have they took they spared no expense to
make it soul-crushing
at every turn there's no like for a know
it is crammed packed with experiments
with the just most dense just you know
outside light offices that you can
imagine it's it's a it's lovely I had a
great time you found your people which I
did farm I love that just talk about
what you know look at this beautiful
math ya know and then I started working
with dr. master when I was undergraduate
and then stayed on for grad school there
and I mean I basically saw as relativity
it was computational relativity so I
looked at binary black hole and her
spirals two galaxies coming together and
they kick off gravitational radiation
looked at specifically my dissertation
was on stability of gauge equations now
Einstein's equations with our form of
gauge system and Hamiltonian said
anyways blah blah blah but the point
being is that well while this this takes
time it takes a lot of like dedication
or a lot of interest a lot of adderall
as well I'm the but I just saw how
horrible academics kind of treated each
other like I wanted it to be like the oh
I'm just interested in stuff and I saw
how
funding was taken away from the people
who were just interested in things and
it was given to the people that were
like trying to there were the people
that you're like I'm not saying that
that guy's making up data but if there
was somebody making up data it's that
guy over there right you know where you
get that feeling where it's sort of like
where is your are you are you doing this
for because you care about science are
you doing this because you have like
some sort of thing and then all of your
time is spent writing grant proposals
you know the professor does professor
writes grant proposals they write grant
proposals and they review work that's
done by graduate students and give them
direction for it so that they can
publish more papers and if you're if
you're not in this in this mindset where
you're just gonna publish a [ __ ] ton of
papers all the time
on the same topic because if you start
to deviate from from your specific field
then people are like ah they have no
discipline they they're not gonna be a
good they're not gonna be a good for it
so you mean you don't get right now at a
real university you don't get no one's
getting tenure until they're like 50 so
I figured if I wasn't gonna have a real
job mom might as well be a comic
interest I missed I missed teaching yeah
I miss being in front of people yeah and
I like jokes and so I'd written a bunch
of one-line jokes and this was still in
Austin I started writing them in Austin
always thinking like I'm gonna come too
I'm gonna do stand-up I'm gonna do
stand-up and just stand up and then I
was out here and what was the pull to go
to the Bay I weighed 270 pounds and you
wanted to be around other non fat people
well I was like I was like I totally go
over and is like we were removing your
choices are in New York or San Francisco
someplace I have to walk where I can't
have a car yeah yeah so we moved out
here and I mean we've moved my
background I just got a job and moved
out here and
that turns out that if you leave
academia I mean I worked at some other
jobs before I worked for MIT Media Lab
for a little bit and and other stuff
doing some cool things but if you if you
leave academia you're never gonna be as
challenged up to that level as you were
in grad school there's really all those
lines and so it depends on how
intellectually curious you are if you're
not very like you you definitely were at
least very good ya was serious yeah
because if you are very very curious
across especially like either one
discipline or many different disciplines
it can really make the outside academic
not fun now the amount of time that
you're spending doing like ten coupled
partial different second-order partial
differential equations stability
solutions looking at that for years on
end and looking at the nutrifix
yeah that depth you're never going to
experience that level of of sort of you
know you're at the forefront of
knowledge and you're taking little cups
of sand and pouring in a little bit more
to make the beach a little bit bigger
and it's you don't the rest of it is
gonna be you're gonna coast a little bit
after that you can still have fun and
still be engaged but you know Coast a
little bit I found it I was super bored
at work because I was doing marketing
data science stuff and that's cool
that's fine they're good people I really
like working with them
but I needed something else and so I
started doing stand-up quick before we
get to juvie the two things you brought
up first is back in Texas when you were
explaining how the within the scientific
to getting to the edge of knowledge and
wanting to pursue that we need to fund
that better we need to make that so it's
not just some person that's making of
data points it's not cool to do with the
foundation of scientific knowledge not
they're saying that they did you're like
you're like something is your ambition
is weird yes and then and then the other
thing that you brought up just a moment
ago was you have this this this really
good way of explaining depth because we
like to talk a lot about depth and
breadth and the way that you can
understand reality and when you go to
you know to such depths of a specific
subsequent physics you are really just
pouring you know on a massive beach full
of sand already you're pouring another
little half cup of so yeah all these
little tiny little incremental advances
you're making at the edge and this is
very important we need people at the
edge of all these different disciplines
that are doing that that type of work
really deep down but they also need to
be valued and so like you know I think
that there's it I mean one of the
biggest troubling March that we should
see at the moment besides everything
else that's troubling is you know for
America during you know Manhattan
Project during after war after you know
going to the moon things like that there
was a huge investment in the brain trust
for the US now the brain trust is
essentially paid for by
military-industrial complex which we
don't have the same like the the public
doesn't have the same visibility into
that component now where people are were
where jobs are in academia is I mean
China and China and and and I mean
Europe is doing Germany is doing doing
well there's a lot of there's a lot of
jobs there but in proportion I mean
China is just China's clearly trying to
be like oh we want to we want to build
up a massive amount of smart people here
you know the way that you raise children
into the
the nutrients and the stimuli that they
need in order to become these super
smart edge thinkers and leaders is I
think most people can do it I don't
think it's nice they're just joking
agree well no I mean I mean you people
most people even adults they can do it
but it's really having foresight to
think about what stimuli children are
absorbing what traumas they are not
exposed to how much love and compassion
and basic I had gave me like a hot dogs
and mag cheese out of a can like come on
it's I think that everybody I think it
was the only thing you have to do like I
hear people all the time like I bought
it about piano two years ago and I was
like oh well I'm gonna learn to play
piano and then I was like oh oh I don't
want to read music so I'm just gonna
learn to play by ear and I mean it's
hard you have to enjoy doing this stuff
and I'm not perfect and maybe if I start
at five then I would be perfect but I
don't think I think that what we've
trained ourselves to do is to make all
these excuses well I didn't get the
right nutrients growing up so I can't
yeah but there are seriously people that
didn't have parents growing up her
parents were drug addicts growing up or
whatever and these are not they didn't
even have anything they didn't I think
that's I think that I think that stuff
serious so we're talking about the the
bell curve right there's generally the
bulk or where they did have the basic
needs met but that there's there's
sometimes it's things like blue Sigma
and mentorship that you need you need a
one-on-one mentorship to get a couple
standard deviations out on these belts
you could do good things in the middle
you can do great things in the middle as
well absolutely absolutely so now so now
take us can you move to the Bay you're
starting to get into comedy doing
stand-up yourself and then you decide
that you're gonna produce your own
comedy show cheaper than therapy that
was pretty easy decide now tell us about
how you decided that and also how you
decide on these twelve comics that you
have to bring on every single week
because this is tough stuff you not only
have to book and manage those twelve
comics you have to book and man you have
to you have to book a man's just
Theater the hundreds of guests that come
on to you know you have a hundred guests
per show pretty much is that it's about
the number and then you have the you
know the the ticket sales and managing
that the finance I mean this is tough
stuff to get you managing over time
especially the political practice
culture how do you pick the right
comedians so tell us about this I think
that there's like basically it just
boils down to I mean so it got started
because I mean if you do if you run a
show you get more regular stage time and
that's what you need in front of in
front of other people to be to be better
at and your your job and then once it
started I was like well I mean comics
are generally self-destructive
irresponsible people so all I have to do
is be a little bit less irresponsible
and a little bit less self-destructive
and I can knock it out of the park and
so I you know I found the the folks at
the shell theater and really like found
a place that they would work with me
while I built this up and you know for
three months we did one show a month
while I figured out well I figured out
cost and we're advertising spend was
doing and who the demographic was coming
in and what was resonating with them and
things like that and but really I think
the the the hardest challenge of
stand-up or any sort of art component is
I am gonna be I'm gonna be me I'm gonna
choose the comics that make me laugh and
the show will be consistent because it
was a reflection of a singular entity
the people that I work with they are the
people that make me laugh once you have
that sort of basis and trust amongst a
group of people then you can say hey
this person made me laugh they did a
good job you know they're not gonna
wreck up the place and so then then we
have additional an additional network of
people and you just build that up over
time so yes
likewise is what this is like and with
what entrepreneurship or art is like is
that
process of building of networks of
trusted people continuing to deliver
high-quality products measures yeah it's
all its yeah yeah so and then after
afterwards or after the show you know I
talk with everybody a glad-hand folks
I'm Sarah who you talk to almost every
single person that ends the show so it's
just very powerful you're asking them
you know why they came out what they're
interested in
I like people I like I hate people but I
like everybody and it's great like I'm
not gonna have to really interact with
them again like I like the concept of
people I'm not bored with them and and
so it's you know it's entertaining and
there's also just from a standpoint of
like maintaining maintaining a consumer
product in a space that is notoriously
like bad to comics comedy clubs are bad
to comics comedy clubs are bad to
audience members literally they are like
you are forced to buy two drinks I'm
gonna charge you
I'm gonna charge you some ticket free
thing I'm gonna force you to buy to fix
no we said now you know I would take
away the drink minimum and the people by
about the same number of drinks anyways
right
because that's what they were gonna do
but they don't have to feel like cattle
and after the show you know it's a it is
what resonates with a lot of people is
like hey they wanted me to be there I
had a good time if you want to continue
partying after the show I'm your man I
want to continue partying with you and
and interact and find out so that I
understand like where my customer is
coming from when someone has a problem
they generally come to me and in
different countries around the world
there's there's we get about 60 to 70
percent of our audience over the course
of the weekend is San Francisco directly
Bay Area you know a little bit less down
south a little bit less out East Bay but
seventy percent say if of those people
50 percent of them will come back within
a year and they'll bring with them two
to three people that's great
yeah well that's I mean it's just word
of mouth so if you build a product that
it has good word of mouth and then that
you know that means any show about a
fourth of the show is direct word of
mouth that that has not that cost
nothing yes that means that I can pay
comics more it means I could keep the
theater stable I can keep the art
community stable and that's a big thing
to give back for somebody who has a tech
job that's because those people are
ruining the city and so I want to at
least keep some some art going and some
community going and and and be
supportive and contributed with a t' and
it's you know that that's quite
important to me and then the fact that I
mean I would literally not I would be a
very very self-destructive person if I
didn't have a way to like channel
creativity to something that was that
was sustainable and and I had an
audience to to to talk with yeah this is
another reoccurring theme that comes up
when we sit down with comedians is that
they like you said at the very beginning
that the stage time in the practice that
you get from producing your own set is
super crucial so you get the ability to
go and perform over and over and over
again and you also have again an outlet
for your own creative talent and you
know you mentioned that you think that
like some of the tech is caused harm
it's harmful and we would we would agree
that some of the some of the protocols
are and to be able to counter that with
your own art and community development
is is critical and that's why we have
ambitious do you know creative
warehousing and a lot of aspiring young
people to be able to execute their
dreams now when you're curating the 12
that you pick for these six six shows
that happen a week how do you pick you
know you were talking about how you pick
them because they're the people that you
trust they built relationships with that
kind of stuff but then how do you how do
you both curate your message as well as
how do you kind of how do you see their
message is being curated in this age of
political correctness well I mean first
of all it means is a bear you have to be
if you're if you're booking a show or
like running club you have to be
you should be aware funny is funny out
of the funny people in the world you
same thing happens in in math they're
underrepresented groups I think that
that providing diversity is a is
definitely a win for having more talent
if it is a meritocracy have more people
be able to enter into the pool and
you'll find and the best people will
race the top and and so I'm making it
making it a place as a club that's
that's welcoming to every
underrepresented minority a woman in
women or not you know they make up more
than half of population and there's not
more than a half the comic survived
they're all white dudes all of them are
like like you know that's the vast
majority of comics and so making sure
that that it is a place where everyone
feels welcome and that everybody is a
has that same reflection of like but
once you're in the green room with
comics you can say anything and
nothing's offensive it's beautiful it's
a lovely thing outside of of of that
back to your the the PC culture or
something I I mean I don't have a
problem there's always been boundaries
there's always been boundaries George
Carlin and the 7:30 words we have 730
words now they just all happened to be
racial epithets so we don't say them out
loud but is that the way you're asking
is a moving target and comedy is comedy
is the thing you don't have
you know Steve Martin's not going to go
out and play King King Tut for a group
of people right now because it moved on
he's not going to wild and crazy guy
he's not doing that it's not Led
Zeppelin right it's a moving it's a
known moving target it's a known
shifting thing the the
a band flow of where those boundaries
are within a society defines what what a
group of people think of it's comedy and
frankly is it as a comedian you even if
you say I hate the boundaries you love
the batteries that's what you watched
you walk right up to the boundary mm-hmm
you walk right up to the boundary and
you tell people look look I'm stepping
on the boundary
I'm stepping over the boundary I'm
having fun oh this is dangerous
someone's gonna be angry most of you are
not gonna be that's where we know the
boundaries there we've anchored at least
five people and made 95 people happy
good boundary yeah yeah yeah they seem
kind of you can kind of the mood so the
boundary this Badri this political
correctness that that exists is a moving
target and maybe we can view it as
something that's continuously moving
towards more and more progress like
ethics of society are evolving to become
more moral more ethical and so then
you're the boundary is continuously
moving kind of a way I think I don't
know I think that people just that that
people feel a lot of they don't feel in
control and I think that while there's a
lot of good things about you know trying
to be more empathetic and and trying to
understand you know different roles and
put yourself in other people's shoes you
can do that without without necessarily
the PC you know sort of culture though
that we have at the moment it just as a
comic though as a comic though it is it
is based specifically it tells you where
the comedy is at so as a comedian you
have two things you have yourself what
you find funny and then what people will
accept and so you have to draw that Venn
diagram and she was out of the center
right there so this is telling you this
is telling you something
and the center I think I think that a
lot of the a lot of folks that that have
interacted with it so if the the the
derogative term is this social justice
warrior or something along those lines
you know it's unfortunate if people
don't feel in control outrage is a is a
form of aggression it's a form of
aggression where somebody wants to
control you
mmm by trying to trying to shame you hmm
and it's if you merely don't have shame
then it's look I'm willing to I'm
willing to fail I don't want I might if
something doesn't work and people don't
laugh and they're upset I'm not gonna
keep doing it yeah yeah but if it was
funny to me I'm gonna try because that's
what the Venn diagram is right and you
get bored and you're like ah you know
what if somebody's angry at me today
it's just it's one more day that
someone's angry at me okay that's fine
like you know you have to really accept
yourself and I think that that that
right now we accept a lot of a lot of
that shame and that's that's part of the
ebb and flow like people will figure
that out as a society and it'll be a
different thing you know it'll be be
different different words different you
know exempt to be to challenge yourself
to be aware to try and be more
empathetic yes I think sympathy is not a
good thing but I think I think empathy
is a good thing get behind nice yeah
sympathy projects that you that they
need your sympathy and so that's that's
wrong but trying to understand and
listen to listen to people then you'll
also know what exactly to mock and I
mean listening to people is how you
listening to people is that like there's
a there's a subconscious component where
you're like ooh that's gonna be good
that's that's gonna be a good joke
that's gonna be right that's gonna be
right there I'm gonna get 99 people and
the one person's gonna feel bad that
they were outraged because everyone else
laughed so hard hmm that's good
yeah I like how you put it in boundary
Brittain perspective of boundaries that
seems to make a lot of sense and also
the way that you explain it in terms of
like your love of like being around the
boundary testing it out and being very
open and not shameful that's super
important not necessarily there's
something about about control like you
said if people wanting to control the
way that other people think as well I
want to I want to go back and forth you
bid on on you know since you're strong
science background along with comedy and
production now your take on exponential
technologies effect on humanity well I
mean I work in the tech world and so I
don't I mean I open terminal I don't I
have the web thing and I will never be a
front-end engineer always open terminal
I don't care I think I think that
technology we've gotten to the point
where what was the arthur c clarke v
rule or something like that that once
the technology becomes so advanced it's
indistinguishable from magic
you know the you know growing up in the
south and the in the sort of deeply
religious component people would be like
the devil put a virus on my computer and
I was like you dude you were looking at
porn like you were looking at porn it
clicked on something and one important
just like I it was it's like it's
indistinguishable from magic
I had a certain because it was so far
removed I think that like technology can
help was I mean if anybody there's - I
work at tickle time what do I do on the
weekends I interact with people wouldn't
even use a microphone interact with
people and I go on a bike ride out to
the to the trees or some something like
that you know I think that how very zen
and the art of motorcycle maintenance
I've made to to have to combat those two
things but I think that that's normal
for everybody I think that that
you know we always want I think we want
technology to solve a lot of stuff and
especially out in the Bay Area we're
like technology this and it's just a
bunch of hype men that are trying to get
their thing funded so they can afford to
buy a house at some point in their life
I don't know way but I don't think
science the incremental incremental
questions for the sake of answers
questions for the sake of managers quit
it sounds [ __ ] boring and it is
that's that's how you get stuff done
that's how you get stuff done and it's
not and it's not glamorous and it's not
an app and it's not anything else that's
how you I mean look come on bacteria is
gonna wipe us out bacteria and stupidity
that's what's gonna wipe us out so how
so on the bacteria like synthetic
biology like no I mean that's that the
bacteria there's a lot of it and mutates
quite quite quickly I mean that's mmm
bacteria I'm virus sorry
good that's we're gonna yeah good you
know it's gonna you gotta you got
antibiotic resistant TB being fomented
and I said it earlier we had a good run
we had a good run blew it
see boy it they're they're they're
fostering it quite prevalently and in
russia right now at the moment and you
know that cuz i watch PBS and they told
me of this thing and i trust it because
they had the front line and they issue
corrections on their website when they
when they do something wrong you know i
think that i mean i'm not gonna have
kids I'm not gonna have kids I don't
that that would be a horrible thing to
bring another person into something
that's clearly on the decline you know I
don't technology's not gonna save us
we're not gonna who wants to I mean I've
heard rocket man it's not Mars is not
the kind of place you want to raise your
kids it's in fact it's cold as ice yeah
yeah and there's no one there to raise
them if you did like it's not
you know even he didn't understand the
science even though it's his job five
days a week but the point being is that
he's making reference to the Elton John
hit song in 1970 something Rocket Man it
was actually a prophetic if anything
yeah that's the one goes Rocket Man
where you got drunk and played it for 12
minutes in the duck suit in Australia
yeah anyways the I digress as a ATD
person who fridges the you bring up you
bring a very important points that
there's a lot on earth that we like to
think about it as code sometimes there's
a lot of new code deployments that need
to happen in order to maximize hope is a
good thing
hope is a good thing hope is a very good
thing but not if it causes you to to
shirk responsibility hmm and the hope
that technology is going to solve
everything for us is impetus right now
for people to just be like but it's fine
to figure it out they'll make some
they'll make some carbon eating bacteria
thing that's gonna and we'll just dump
it in the ocean it'll eat the plastic -
it's fine technology isn't gonna solve
everything for us it's gonna solve
everything for them for who's them well
I just have a inclination that we are a
genetically modified organism there is
an intelligent alien dark villain that's
what they do they just read it be there
ridiculed on right there the closer I
get to the truth
yeah I think I think that the more that
people like Ron and others that think in
these very abstract ways about what's
actually happening on playground earth
as an experiment I think that we need to
prop up those ideas and test them as
best as we can because those are very
exciting and enjoy already have so many
like here's the thing we're a lot of
problems that we know we know what we
need to do like here's the thing
separate your recycling don't use
plastic stuff free that's not that's not
a good solution actually the good
solution is to make it and then make
biodegradable and not even use
single-use like plastic material yeah
and then not and then don't don't have
kids and encourage your friends not to
have kids and encourage the courage for
people to get in science and solve
scientific problems and an incentive ice
on solving so yeah it's been that time
because of your scientist you're not
getting laid so you just that'll stop
the case that's not always true I think
there's there's ways around that they
didn't have they didn't have really a
see in the rlm and so it's sort of like
there's always just like they did they
did have a see but it was always just
like this patina of gross Ness it was
there and it's not know speaking of back
here yeah yeah yeah it wasn't so give us
your give us your your thought for you
know this is will be an interesting
interesting to ask you this what is your
one kind of like skill that you would
recommend people you were active oh you
were recommending some thoughts earlier
on this like what is something good to
develop with like with vigilance as a
skill directed practice that is the that
is I mean if you want to change
something then then do that right that
don't you can start but directed
practice means that you have to take
incremental steps you're okay with
failure and so practice practice failure
I mean the the I want to get here I'm
here I think I want to get here maybe
along the path I don't even want to get
there anymore
but I want to start
start the path so people will make the
they'll say this gap is too large or
they'll start they'll start hearing no
[ __ ] up and then they'll say oh well I'm
not good at it math is hard I can't do
it like no math is hard that's why it's
fine
that's why you should do it like take
the incremental thing you don't like it
doesn't matter what age you're we're
background it is like not none of us are
gonna be Einstein it's not gonna happen
like you to use that as an excuse a puts
too much tremendous pressure on one
person to be like oh it winds gonna
solve everything for us no you know
everybody it can contribute may not be
in the same flashiness but you do
something that you enjoy and taking
incremental steps like there whatever 35
by piano those are very beautiful words
did you get a baby grand or just a you
know I got a core guess for you want an
electric one yeah I got a weighted keys
that's fine yeah those are beautiful
therapy too sorry yeah yeah back to the
show yeah yeah yeah music absolutely is
two really powerful words directed
practice yeah for anyone when when when
technology has over overcome our habits
in many ways if we just bounce back and
forth between things all day long and
we're not necessarily directing our
practice towards something that we find
most meaningful in our lives and taking
those incremental steps to become a
master have master yet something Ron and
I have a couple last questions for you
on the show first one is are we alone in
the cosmos no but we're probably not
gonna meet the other people we're not
other things are they're too far away
like speed light is just sorry
so why there's no God good next question
[Laughter]
you want to talk about the others in the
cosmos that you which is the Drake
Equation
created by a hip-hop rapper from Canada
who also really enjoyed and then started
today to 18yo those we're way
it was mm-hmm
no they the Drake Equation is
essentially like just how large is a
universe what's the probability what's
the floor of it there's a there is a
diminishing chance that there are no
other sentient beings but one out of
every five stars has an earth-like
planet sure
yeah but then what's the earth-like
planet or so earth-like planet is an
interesting question earth-like planet
means like if you if you put butter in
the fridge right no this is your
publicity we melt your mouth but ER you
melt butter you put it in the fridge
right it's in a it's in a container like
this well the butter separates it
separates into water protein normal fat
cream fat mmm that's all well what an
earth-like planet means is technically
that if you have a you have a
gravitational pull from the Sun from a
Sun a star here and you have a heat
distribution that it comes out long this
way yes what a earth-like planet is is
the peak is the peak spectrum of where
you would expect water yeah so where if
you look at where where water droplets
would form there's two places there's
one that's here right third have a third
planet third planet from the from the
Sun and then there's one that's outside
of the gravitational force around
Jupiter yeah which is Titus or whatever
pocket playing it I might well it
doesn't matter what their names or not
well there is there's well Enceladus and
Titan I don't know yet oh oh some moon
around Jupiter
both Saturn and then and then jupiter
has europa which is the other one that
was a bad album but go on but but but
yet so then that's another location for
well drivers Zooropa that was a
different that's another location for
water so yes yes anyways the point is
like I don't care about that I care
about the math the math I don't care
about the name
I'm sure talk about what the name is
yeah well the math fasting because then
that's what you can see as these little
potentials for life around stars yeah
but anyway the point being is that water
is the largest aqueous solution like the
Bose base aqueous solution and your
that's what you need to have to have
something that can combine and have
ready available thing so the if we did
meet another Senate being they would
probably be carbon-based I mean they're
they're gonna be carbon-based that could
be nickel alloy based they're
carbon-based they had some chain of
events that propagated in the same way
the propensity for that is a apparently
nonzero so yeah whether it's the same
time the we probably have something to
learn from them we probably don't have
anything to I mean we've been trying to
share with them since the since at least
the mid sixties now although they made
so on Voyager 2 that they made the
Voyager Voyager 2 and they cross Sagan
but you put a picture of like you humans
on there and they made them take the
nipples off the lady which is [ __ ]
this is what this is how politicians
[ __ ] [ __ ] up they made that they
seriously refined these they live it on
that gold plate no nipples on the gold I
think the dude had nipples I think the
dudette nipples and they were like no
nipples on women yeah that's ridiculous
and so if they're watching this like
Instagram and then they aliens come here
they're gonna be like what the [ __ ]
women have nipples this is [ __ ] up and
I'm like they're the only ones that need
nipples like why are they on the men why
do we need to have this long John this
is simulation so we must ask you are we
in a simulation depends what you define
as a simulation I suppose that it's it
it there is a mathematical regularity to
the universe so that appears to be
causal so in that regards yes the
implication that's that it is a
simulation for someone I believe is
false but I mean you can compute any of
the individual things so it makes it
makes a computation but I think that
there's what was the not shorter who was
the starts with the II forget to do his
name but it was like the miracle of the
miracle of the unreasonable
effectiveness of mathematics to describe
the physical world that's that's that's
all you're seeing that's loose no I a
tissue is somebody somebody else a
physicist but it was the it's
unreasonable effectiveness of
mathematics to describe the physical the
school don't think it's an experiment on
behalf of some like like we're gonna
jump into our own little experiments in
the next couple decades ourselves no I
mean it's the the I mean it doesn't
matter if I do or not like there's you
find me a way to test it questions for
the sake of answers that's why that's
what we're doing where we are we're
gonna be probing this and we'll I don't
think it follows mathematical regularity
so I think that the the more important
component to to act what is the what is
the physical manifestation outside
observer outside already dictates some
space time thing but space time probably
came from a self-organized component of
emerging two dimensions emergent
phenomena perhaps but outside and before
and after are all constructs that are
part of part of the regularity of
mathematics so I don't and it doesn't
seem like it doesn't seem like a
worthwhile question for me to ask you
think that all all that this is all that
is is kind of the kind of like the code
proof since the big bang we're all
interconnected it's all one
consciousness are you on that side of
yeah there's only like four equations
though and those that's what governs
everything and does like the principles
of physics if you if there's a god
that's the principle of physics or
principles of physics we just it we can
discover them though that's what you
should be working real hard to discover
because it seems like people want to be
like is there a god like you don't even
know physics shut up
[Laughter]
yeah yeah yeah yeah great and then
because the equations are ya got in wait
can you please answer the last question
alright alright what's the most
beautiful thing in the world I think
that there's that there is it for me
right now it's why I do what I do that
intense joy when you've made a group of
people laughs in a in a very
particularly in a visceral way like
against against their will the if you
just told them words without it being a
joke they would say don't don't say that
that's horrible but when you say in a
joke format and people laugh and they
laugh hard it is it is a you feel very
it's a very human to pretty much the
only human experience right is that
you're deeply you're deeply connected
yeah I don't have that I I like oxytocin
and I like and I like making people
laugh
yeah oxytocin is the one that love drug
could produce if you are infatuated with
somebody it turns out that they hate you
but it's a at least you still get to
produce the drug for a little bit it's
electrifying what that feeling of being
up on a stage and and really making
people laugh their asses off that's very
beautiful yeah yeah I mean it's that's
that's why you it's very addicting and
hopefully you just get better at it yeah
I'm better at it and more comfortable
and and you know better at it is is is
the incremental you know directed
practice of being able to fail yep yep
Devils were powerful restorative
practice next time someone asks you if
you believe in God make sure to tell
them you don't even know physics why are
you asking this question everyone get on
that directed practice I love it John
this has been super fun thank you for
coming on to the show
absolutely yeah well I guess I might be
shaded we wish you the best the cheaper
than therapy forever
thank you so much for tuning in and we
highly recommend giving us your thoughts
in the comments below on the subjects
that we talked about in this episode get
chatting with other people about comedy
about PC culture about what it's like to
go and start your own comedy
conversations with more people who shout
out to Ron Vargas for producing and
directing thank you so much we love you
and appreciate you also check out John's
links below John's raising money on his
patreon right now to do more fair at the
souls of cheaper than therapy go and
support him check him out on Twitter as
well check out cheaper than therapy if
you're in the Bay Area go and check it
out Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday
shows all four days a week go and check
them out and support the artists and
entrepreneurs are below as well support
us go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you so much
get that directed practice in peace
[Music]